welcome to this video playing Prince
panic from from the Netherlands I am
Billy Hendricks and platon before you on
video and I remember that I had some
trouble with Blackie I hardly have
played him with Wyatt just noticed that
okay we got a king's indian sameish will
see 5 term oh this is all d I don't
remember I think this is the right one
no he has now transferred had the Queen
to h5 which is rather unusual for this
for this opening but add some some newer
ideas to the position probably
as I probably have mentioned in some
earlier video where I played among he is
the author of phone of a random
well-received book I think it also wants
some book of the year what I'm so that's
the funny toddler move for us to think
later it's really enjoyable something to
to check out okay so i just made rather
non-committal moves here Brooksie one
Queen d2 the sort of stuff you usually
do in the Roxy bind okay and maybe it's
got Bishop h6 son yeah well that's it's
not the end of the world yes our beehive
I thought I thought 95 would still be a
good reply simply because if you take he
as he takes I am not quite sure what the
queen is is doing here
okay maybe you can exchange d4 and play
Queen e5 something like that maybe
yeah it's really weird to have the Queen
over on age 5 hmm but I'm not sure that
I'm really threatening anything in
regards to the Queen likes like a fall
or something I'm not really threatening
to trap a dorm or gain anything yeah
black looks fairly solid here probably
played this too too simplistic and a too
simplistic fashion then I like my g5
seat XD maybe it is spending lots of
time I thought Queenie five now would be
good yeah this is also interesting
looking at this rook but I have a before
right why not F for some reason not to
play a form yeah well I need you i need
you i really cannot i cannot give up the
C file so i need to play a form it's a
bit weakening here but where was it
supposed to go yeah yeah yeah I thought
about that I'm not not sure or if this
is what what kind of trade this is I
need to try it anyway so I might as well
play it he may be intending to go f5
yeah i think we probably get the bishop
and game and rather draw one I guess
okay i'm not sure about all that if he
goes before i have to shove a six try to
fight for the C file I thought you
should just just tried everything off
our that was his idea interesting
but I'm not convinced really
the thing is so I have my king involved
and he doesn't
now maybe you can take an f6 oh yeah I'm
still probably not much going on
yeah I could play a 6cm but i'm not sure
if this is a good move
a ver it gained so much space would be
kind of surprising it wouldn't be good
you can he can go to d6 okay but look at
this Bishop with Bishop before I'm
covering it and he he can hardly move
but it's hard to say how i should make
any any progress and maybe even go to e5
with the king yeah not sure but ice
under some pressure still spending some
time now it's always tricky of you don't
have any yeah this is the the most
obvious move
and probably should go King e5 Wow I
don't I don't get it am I not just
winning the pawn ost3 here the the big
point c 3 Phi if I if I regroup to a
Tekkit yeah then you will place you
three it's a trick okay if we go see
three oh no no no this isn't c3 is not a
threat at the moment I can just take it
so i can now i can try to try to make
progress here let's uh let's see
I'm wondering about g5g five f5 and take
then h5 this not sure not sure but this
is this is good anyway this I didn't
expect he just takes it may be a this is
right the right decision but I'm i was
i'm so surprised if I sped though it's
this looks funny I think
okay let's seem just um time morning
yeah that's no reason not to retreat
first threatening to just to just
approach him with the king black
forfeits on time I have the the deep on
make the home run hmm yeah I wonder
about him after a fine if I can take i'm
not sure i don't think i can i was just
intending to drop it back end and go for
our 4-h five or maybe here and then aged
five better protect the pawn him yeah
this keeps keeps an edge but it said
winning but this doesn't seem to win
please the computer computer says so and
now it now it gives us us winning I had
the hunch that it would win but it
wasn't sure this is oops yeah even that
is ok just I'm just promoting but it
gives this as the best defense
relatively best defense just giving
giving up off pawns to gain go here
however this is this is winning ok so
this then I would have one indeed but he
took on on f5 not not sure this this
should be a wind really yeah a for
didn't help it not I'm not one hundred
percent sure how to achieve the the win
here are probably because I can also
play a for myself him at some point to
put him in solo zoosk one
like this and he needs to jettison the
pawn yeah I know it looks like a
blockade but if you if you look at this
position I have this idea but should be
three covering both King here and then
at the right moment play seven I can put
this on the board just to to make the
point and and right now I have this one
and this this and and wins rather rather
easily I just need to engineer this
breakthrough and I at the end I have
those pawns to to attack as well the
endgame probably should be a row with
good play yeah in certainly enough the
computer says who is close to winning
here which I cannot believe it wants to
play care for him now no I don't I don't
I don't believe that but widest close to
winning all right let's not make an hour
long video out of that thanks for
watching I hope you enjoyed it